- [Interviewer] All right.
Richard, Richard, where
are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- I grew up in New York City.
Er Manhattan.
- [Interviewer] And
how was your childhood?
You grew up with both your parents?
- Um, I grew up with my mother.
Both my parents were in the service.
I was in military school
and, uh, that's it.
We took it from there.
They separated when I was three.
It was a little disturbing, but yeah.
Yeah.
These are things that you
have to deal with sometimes.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have brothers and sisters?
- I have one sister.
- [Interviewer] And
how was your childhood?
How was your childhood?
- Kinda crazy.
- [Interviewer] In what ways?
- Um. Physically. Sexually.
Uh, It was a lot of different changes.
Um, I mean, if you want
to get somewhere in life
sometimes you had to do, I mean,
I was a, uh, I was an escort some time.
- [Interviewer] At what age?
- At 13.
- [Interviewer] 13?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] On whose watch?
Your mom?
- No, no.
My mom had to work just to keep us afloat
and uh, I tried not be a burden to her.
Uh, what I did was I tried
to do the best in school
that I could.
- [Interviewer] But then
who, at 13 who's kind of?
- School was maybe five blocks away.
I walked there and I was an alter boy
serving, uh, Cathedral,
St. Patrick's Cathedral
with Cardinal Cooke O'Connor and uh,
it was a different experience for me.
I was an alter boy.
I used to go up to serve
to get me outta trouble.
I felt at ease.
All I wanted to do is
make something out of my
my life, just like my dad.
My dad was an electrician.
Uh, he was in the Navy and,
uh, I took it from there.
You know, he put, my
mother pushed me as much
as she could and I did the
most I could to help out.
- [Interviewer] So you brought home money?
- I did.
- [Interviewer] And how
long did this go on?
- For the rest of my life.
- [Interviewer] Oh, really?
- Yeah.
Until mom passed away, so I had moved out.
Got married.
Uh, had my daughter.
My daughter is 21.
She's in college, straight A student.
- [Interviewer] Great.
- That's so cool.
Uh, I was with San Hard
for most of my life.
Yeah, but they're doing out
here right now is they're
doing tunnel work out here.
Um, I'm a demolitions expert.
So that's what I did.
It was, it, it was a different experience.
I'm red.
Somebody took me under their wing
and uh, I learned quite a bit.
It was a real, real experience.
I mean, on the job training.
Well, you can't get that anywhere.
- [Interviewer] You get to blow stuff up.
- That's, that's well,
it's not so much just that
as being safe.
It's, you know, doing the late fuses
and stuff like that.
Really doing explosions
instead of uh, uh, you know
leaving the pile right there.
Chopping an excavator
down, fill a bucket up and
send it back up to the top.
Uh, it was, it was cool.
- [Interviewer] So that was your career
for a lot of your life?
- For quite some time.
Probably 10, 12 years.
- [Interviewer] But, but
you say the escorting thing
was kind of going on for...
- That went on.
I was about 20 and uh,
it was, it was weird.
I couldn't get used to certain things.
I, I did the most I could to make the most
that I could to help out at home.
- [Interviewer] Did your parents wonder
where the money was coming from?
- Yeah.
All the time.
- [Interviewer] And what'd you tell them?
- I lied.
Uh, there's just certain
things that was just
better left unsaid for me.
- [Interviewer] And you weren't
doing it for your own gain.
You were just helping your family.
- I was.
And then I started, yeah.
I took an apartment
with uh, this nice lady.
Yeah.
The Sheffield Towers on West 57th.
And that's where she
ran her whore business.
And she did quite well.
So what I did was I was just
pretty much just an arm piece.
(Chuckles)
- Uh. It was. It was different.
- [Interviewer] So you were an art piece
for the rich ladies on
the Upper East Side?
- Pardon?
What's that?
- [Interviewer] You're the art piece
for the rich ladies on
the Upper East Side?
- I was.
I was.
And they certainly enjoyed it.
Yeah.
You made them feel important.
You put them on, you know, at the top
and treat them with some
decor and a lot of respect
and they liked it.
You know, liked to feel important.
That was cool.
As a woman should be treated.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. Yeah.
How, how long did this go on?
- As I said, til I was 20.
- [Interviewer] Til you're 20.
And then, it, have you, have
you done anything similar
to that after your twenties?
- No.
I been made offers and uh,
there's not much just for it.
There.
I didn't even bother.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
So today you're living on Skid Row.
- No, today I'm living in
a Section Eight apartment.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
- Uh, yeah.
- [Interviewer] So you got housing?
- I just moved.
Uh, what?
- [Interviewer] You got housing?
- I did.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- It only took two years.
(chuckles)
Uh. Uh.
- [Interviewer] Are you
using any of the drugs
on the street?
- I did at one point.
I did.
- [Interviewer] Which ones?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Which drug?
- Heroin.
- [Interviewer] Heroin.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And you got off?
- Yeah, I did.
- [Interviewer] How'd you get off it?
- I was tired of it.
I was getting older.
I'm 57.
Uh, and I had a lot more important things
in my life going on.
Like my wife.
My daughter going to college.
I gotta be there for them.
So, so it was important.
- [Interviewer] So you're off drugs now?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How difficult
was it for you get clean?
Off heroin?
- It was your determination,
your commitment.
That's all.
You have to want to.
You gotta be tired.
Gotta be tired.
- [Interviewer] Looking back at your life,
What, what do you wish
had happened differently?
Or what, what, what regrets do you have?
- [Richard] I wish my mother
and father stayed together.
Which was uh, important
for me because that was where
I actually got my strength
and my power from.
I mean, he pushed me to
where I needed to be.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Richard] And I trusted him.
Which is not the easiest
thing in the world to do.
You just don't trust everybody.
And then when they both passed on, uh,
jeez I just started
growing up at 38 years old.
My mother kinda sheltered me
from this jungle and I was
totally unprepared for it.
Didn't know what to expect
but I was going to see what
I was going to experience.
And, but I'm raising a
daughter and being a miner.
- [Interviewer] And when
did you come to Los Angeles?
- Uh? I came to Los
Angeles because I wanted to
do some finish work.
- [Interviewer] At what age?
- Uh, I was, jeez I was 54.
- [Interviewer] Oh, just recently.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And Skid Row is perhaps
the worst part of Los Angeles.
- It sure was, but I'll tell you what.
It opened my eyes to a lot of things,
gave me some decision
and gave me some direction
on where I wanted to go.
I knew I hit one of them like that.
I knew my mother put a lot
of effort into teaching me
or showing me how it was and
what was important in her life.
To her.
And uh, she always asked me for my advice
and how I felt about
what she was asking me.
I tell her straight out.
Uh, it's very important
to have a mentor guide.
If you don't, I tell you when I was,
I did a couple of years in prison.
And you see these young
kids, they're locked
up with their fathers.
How do you do that?
How, how do you do that?
I saw, uh in New Jersey,
what I did is I started a
transition boarding house.
A halfway house, so to speak.
From ISP.
And they had to come
into the house, pay rent,
go to work, make their
meetings, so forth and so on.
And I was there to help
them and point them
in the right direction.
And it was successful.
Being out here.
It needs a lot more attention.
And it would be, it would
take up a lot of your time.
But I tell you, when it's
all said and done, you'll get
at least a few good guys that really want
to change their lives
and do something with it.
You know, it's all I heard out of them was
I want to do something
different with my life.
I don't want to work in a goddamn bank.
I don't want to sell drugs.
I don't want to do this.
I don't want to do that.
You know, I want to do something different
that's going to mean
something with my life.
That was cool.
That inspired me.
Uh, so they needed a little push.
And not something you can
just read out of a book.
You know what I mean?
Yes. Or rather, um.
Yeah. Yeah, because they weren't
accepted from anybody else.
But I don't know if it's not real or
you're not telling them
the truth, you know.
How to be accepting and
they want to change and do
something different.
Me, myself, I certainly wanted
to do something different.
So I was trying to fit in.
You know, I, I wanted to be useful.
I didn't want to be a waste.
I know God didn't put me on
this Earth to be a waste.
You know, I mean, you walk around
and you see some of the people
around here it's like, Jesus
what are you doing every day?
Is this it?
And uh, you have to create your own ideas
and what you want to put out or put forth.
That's okay.
Yeah. So like I said,
being a mentor for some
some people are younger gentlemen.
Uh, it's definitely.
I'm not gonna.
It's the positive way to go.
You're there.
You're showing them the way to go.
You're living and doing as you should do.
And this is it guys, this
is what life is all about.
You can go out there, you work,
you make a paycheck.
Put it on the table, give it to your wife,
take care of your kids.
And uh, well, but raising
kid is pretty tough.
I'm gonna tell ya.
I only had one and I did it myself.
And it's hard.
- [Interviewer] You did it
yourself without your wife?
- I did.
- [Interviewer] Where was your...
- Going to work. I was up in Manhattan.
- [Interviewer] Where was your wife?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Where was the mother?
- The mother was down in Jersey.
- [Interviewer] Why did she leave?
- Uh, using cocaine and drugs.
She couldn't stop.
She worked for South Belmont police
as a dispatcher and stuff.
And I just thought, oh.
There were a few things
that took place and happened
and I couldn't allow that
to happen to my daughter.
(car horns blaring)
I didn't want her to fall
into a bunch of whore world.
Excuse my language.
Yeah. Yeah.
So I wanted to make sure
she had every opportunity.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Richard] And that was important.
What it did for me.
That was cool.
- [Interviewer] I see.
Richard, well thank you
so much for talking to me.
- Absolutely.
- [Interviewer] And good
luck with everything.
Very interesting.
Thank you.